if you haven't tried the spectator
magazine before then do give us a try
we've got
a rather unusually generous introductory
offer right now one pound a week for the
first year you can avail yourself of
this rather uneconomic for us anyway
offer on spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer
[Music]
so the prequel to game of thrones is
released next week about the house of
tragerian which was eventually captured
by an underestimated woman who went on
to slay all of her opponents and take
the throne in related news liz trust is
now very close to being made leader of
the conservative party with a few more
weeks to go left of the tory leadership
campaign the she has got more mp and
support now than russia smack and the
polls still suggest she's ahead amongst
the general members by a ratio of three
to one but the race still continues in
this week's magazine katie balls looks
at what sort of government liz troy
smiled up might end up running and she
joins me now as does isabel hardman um
so katie list trust has got the
reputation of being quite a you know
amiable she likes a laugh she's good fun
but not always the most forgiving of
person you wouldn't want to be one of
her enemies yet she will leave this
leadership campaign with quite a few
enemies what's going to happen to them
when her cabinet is announced
well i think some of these and perhaps
more than not will be heading to
political siberia
you have a situation where i think in
some cases such as for example in the
case of dominic raab who is a rishi
sunak backer who i think is seen to have
been particularly problematic by the
trust camp because he wrote an op-ed in
which he likened liz truss's economic
plans to an electoral suicide note i
don't there's any chance really of
dominic raab having a role in liz
truss's government or being offered one
now
given what he said he would probably say
no you would imagine at the offer but
the offer won't be coming i think also
figures such as michael gove who has not
endorsed rishi sunak but who i think has
long been a foe of liz trusses when it
comes to the cabinet some say they have
a very jovial relationship but i think
jokes aside they disagree on lots of big
issues particularly trade
and uh there is a sense in the trust
camp that when gove is given a position
partly because he's a very skilled
minister he tends to extend his brief i
mean you know dip into other people's uh
departments what they're doing and
therefore it's probably safer uh to have
them on the back benches
and there's lots of questions such as if
she actually has to lead a government uh
will she be doing some big unifying
measures
i think part of the issue is so many
jobs have been promised or at least
supporters of liz trust believe they
have been promised jobs that there's not
actually that much space um to offer too
many uh across to the other camp i think
rishi sanak will be offered a job but um
few would expect him to take that and
it's unlikely to be a particularly
senior role and the let's of course see
what the voting margin is if liz trust
wins so that's michael gove out that's
rishi sunak out that's dominic grab out
all pretty big beasts and by the way
michael gove hasn't said a word against
liz trust during this campaign but but
you're saying it's because interestingly
an ideological split that she's more of
a free trader where michael gove has
been more protectionist over the years
and she you i mean during government
list trust ended up in the wrong she on
the losing side of that argument and i
remember one um i heard anyway of one
meeting in cabinet where she was
basically saying look boris um we're
never going to get a deal with america
if agriculture is not on the table and
michael gove was chief amongst his
voices saying we are not going to let
our agricultural sector be as he put it
put it on the altar of
a sacrificial gift to america so fair
enough they but they disagree but when
this trust becomes prime minister do you
think we're going to get
more of a free trading because she lost
out to gov in that trade argument
there's nobody to lose to lose to her
now so do you think she's going to have
a change of policy and be more free
trading and actually put for example
agriculture on the table in a free trade
deal with america
so so i think
her government will be very pro free
trade and also i mean you mentioned
michael gove i remember at the time of
that dispute um writing a column where
uh a trust supporter um branded them the
waitrose protectionists and this
included uh michael gove i think george
eustis too they they were regarded by uh
trusted supporters as the access of evil
being only protectionist
and so i think there is a question as to
of course how far does her rhetoric go
when she has to get mps to support
measures um but i do think if you look
at the people who will probably be in
the prime positions so quasi-cuatang is
likely to be the of them
um you know liz trust as prime minister
is very pro free market and there will i
think be a switch in the balance of
power and actually moving towards more
ambitious deals because i think that uh
liz trust would probably like to go
further for example in that australia
free trade deal and she than she was
able to do partly because of the what
she was coming against in whitehall and
also from various forces within the
cabinet might she revisit the australia
trade deal in katie
well i think there's there's a chance to
try and revisit some of these things of
course she's going to have a pretty full
entry when when she first gets in so i
think they'll want to be more ambitious
with the free trade deals and i think
australia is seen as a key ally but of
course the government has now changed in
australia and i think when she first
comes in of course that the biggest
issue on her table will be cost of
living and i imagine that will occupy
quite a lot of time within the first few
weeks
so free trade reforms isabel perhaps
more trade deals what would this trust
do domestically well in lots of ways we
haven't had a great deal of detail about
what she plans to do domestically um but
i think there are some interesting hints
one of them is um on the nhs which is
obviously gonna be a huge issue
electorally uh over the next couple of
years in the run-up to the election and
we've seen increasingly distressing
stories about people being uh you know
stuck under makeshift shelters whilst
waiting uh for 14 hours for an ambulance
and so on and we're only going to hear
more and more of these um
stories so that the pressure to do
something on the nhs is going to grow
and the hint that liz trust has dropped
there is um
slightly concerning for those of us who
follow um nhs reform which is that she
seems to want to do more of it even
though the current um changes that have
only just been enacted in the health and
social care act 2022
are only just bedding in she seems to
want to flatten the layers of management
within the health service which would
require um a huge amount of upheaval at
a time that i'm not sure the health
service has any elastic left and
certainly not for the sort of things
like moving managers around and and
changing structures that take up a huge
amount of time and don't necessarily
impact on you know clinical outcomes
waiting times and she's only got
something like 18 months realistically
before the next election so if you're
looking at an incredibly condensed
period of time nhs reform typically
takes a year to think of the reform and
four years to carry it out so what she
might try to crunch something like this
because let's face it the nhs is already
looking like it's in crisis let alone a
winter crisis we're looking at some flu
levels in australia which are quite high
we're also looking at the potential of
pensioners dying of the cold i mean we
all know the link between house
temperatures and the over 80s ending up
in hospital so nhs is looking for an
incredibly difficult period of time but
you think liz trusts would still do nhs
reform in the middle of what it's
looking like in nhs crisis well look she
said that repeatedly throughout this uh
leadership contest that she thinks that
the nhs should have fewer middle
managers that there should be a collapse
in the layers of management within the
health service i suspect that that may
not end up being a massive reform agenda
once she comes into
office for all the reasons that you just
listed and i suspect there are two
reasons for her saying it one is
probably that you know she is
essentially a she's a think tanker
politician isn't she she's someone who
likes coming up with ideas likes
challenging the consensus
finds the way in which
policies and structures operate
interesting but doesn't necessarily sit
back and think well is now the time to
be doing this is this the right thing to
do or even um i think some of her
critics who i've been talking to over
the past few days and would say thinking
about what's happening at the moment and
the second thing is
people just love bashing nhs management
um which is kind of ironic because it
was introduced by margaret thatcher um
which who is you know obviously the
person who we must all sort of say peace
be upon her during this contest as much
as often as possible um but she was the
one who who recognized that the health
service was in complete chaos without
any managers with these sort of bizarre
committees of doctors that were sort of
run along post-war military lines um so
again i think that's probably a sign
that trust hasn't looked into this too
much then we've got um just moving on
from from the nhs which i always find
hard to do and we do have the we've got
the debate over handouts um in relation
to the cost of living crisis but what
might she do about welfare what might
she do about um economically inactive
people and the people who rishi sunak
talks about quite a lot who
are on unemployment benefit at a time of
a tight labor market that's uh five
million of them yeah there's rather a
lot yeah
she's going to approach anything like
this she will need a crack team of
commandos around her do you know
anything about for example who are chief
of staff's going to be who she's going
in for delivery
so there's been lots of rumors and i
think uh team trusts are very keen to
not look too much as though they are
planning for government so as to look as
you know uh they've decided the the the
result of the leadership contest was
already a done deal
um but we know that liz truston is
spending about half her time planning
for government the polls put her very
far ahead and some of the rumors for
example you've had people say oh david
frost uh the former uh brexit negotiator
he should be her chief of staff and he
has been backing liz trust you also have
people pointing to david canzini uh who
has been a number 10 under boris johnson
and saying that actually david canzini
could have that type of role i think one
of the issues of david canzini is
actually some of the boris johnson
loyalists many of them are backing this
trust are actually a bit skeptical about
david kansai when you break it down into
the number 10 factions and i think the
name which i think uh
you haven't heard so much about i think
is a probable pick is actually ruth
porter and now ruth porter is a former
advisor to liz trust liz trust i think
foreign has always made sure to keep in
close contact with those who have worked
for her who she has worked well with and
trust even if they are no longer on the
payroll so to speak
and uh reports have been playing a very
key role in terms of the campaign and i
think the reason that it seems quite
likely she'll get such a senior role is
there a sense that a i think liz trust
wants to surround herself with people
she trusts we know it's going to be a
very tough um you know first 100 days
but also people who understand her and
i've worked her previously i think um as
opposed to perhaps you know the bigger
names amongst mps
isabelle and katie thanks very much
indeed
[Music]
you